hey guys so happy Apple watch today I'm
kind of excited because I've got an
Apple watch right here it's not the
Apple watch that probably most of you
guys are thinking that I have on my arm
it is a vintage think different Apple
watch but if you can see I'm just gonna
take it off if you can see the second
hand actually goes backwards
you are so freakin trendy Apple oh my
god it's amazing so before I started
making this video I did a little bit of
googling but the only thing that I ended
up actually finding was videos and
articles about the current Apple watch
that's coming out and then I got
sidetracked reading information about
that and completely forgot what I was
originally looking for so I just thought
I would sit down and make this video
before the Sun Goes Down and I lose all
of my lights
my dad was searching through all of my
stuff back at my parents house looking
for fun little artifacts that I could
use to put my book and he found this in
my things and he sent me a picture and
then he sent me a video and I was
freaking out I don't know where I got it
but I got it a long time ago it's
beautiful and I really I really loved it
so much it really makes me happy
which leads me to the current gen Apple
watch I am so torn I don't know what to
do I don't know which one to get this is
it's such a dilemma because I don't
necessarily want the sport watch because
I really like the fancier bands and I
really want one of the stainless steel
faces I don't I should get like the
infinity loop one or the the little
linked one I should probably look up
what they actually are calling it
there's so many freaking options it's
like come on you're stressing me out
eisah gonna be so difficult I've also
been looking at the Apple watch icon
since the last update on my phone it
just appeared there and I'm like bro I
want to use you so which one do you guys
think I mean the biggest disappointment
for me was finding out that the rose
gold one was $10,000 I was like no no
it's kind of disappointing because I
personally loved rose gold jewelry I
love actually I love rose gold that's
usually what I go for but I think that
I'm gonna have to skip out on that
because you know what you're insane
what do you want it's a silly watch I
mean I'm thinking about if I have to
sleep outside I will sleep outside for
it I actually don't think I'm gonna be
able to sleep outside I'll sleep outside
I will cancel everything that I have to
do I'll do it will be the first time
anyway let me
your thoughts let me know if you guys
have any idea where this thing came from
because it's so awesome God yourself so
beautiful I'll see you guys my next
video make sure you leave me some
comments below and let me know let me
know all your thoughts I mean all your
secrets
see you next vid